incredibly sad very very sad we met them
before any of us were on reality
television
there's the mutual friends and they were
always a lovely couple Hill Housewives
of Orange County stars Heather and Terry
Dubrow
react to Beverly Hills couple David in
Yolanda Foster's shocking split
I think Yolanda's an incredible mother
and I'm sure the timing of the
announcement had something to do with
her children especially her son who's
still at home with her and protecting
them and I you know I just wish them
both the best do you think the show puts
added strain on relationships you expose
things to the public that you normally
wouldn't expose it seriously marriage is
difficult I think marriage and public
eye is difficult and you have to deal
with tabloids and all that sort of thing
but marriage on reality television I
think the reality show is a test if your
relationship is solid you stay so it has
chinks in your armor those become major
cracks but the problem is is that every
marriage has eveson flows to it so when
you're on television especially on a
reality show and you're having an ebb
it's hard we I didn't have you know I
think our second seize on the show and
it was so hard yeah but we never came
close to breaking up no but but just
having an out there and have people talk
about you in that way is so upsetting
and then you have children it's hard
Tayler AIDS Foundation I was so excited
when they asked me to light the tree
here at the Abbey I mean
- [ __ ] about Dollywood